inside this sprawling western New York
Factory the future of America's
high-speed rail is starting to take
shape in the same spot where trains have
been serviced built and rehabbed since
the 1850s Stanley Hall is the
third-generation Stanley Hall to work
here and it's not just my father and
grandfather you know my brother comes in
here and works had several cousins that
work here when I was first hired my
uncle was one wood that helped me a lot
get in here it wasn't enough that your
dad they start as a shell before some of
the 800 who work in this Cornell New
York plant build them into the trains
that will replace Amtrak's aging
first-generation high speed rail effort
the Acela former Delta Airlines CEO
Richard Anderson now runs Amtrak how
important to the future of Amtrak is the
newest seller it's incredibly important
it really lays out a clear vision for
what short haul intercity passenger rail
transportation can do for this country
and this country is going to need it in
more and more quarters because
Millennials don't want to drive and you
cannot add enough Lane miles for a
hundred million more people the updated
Acela trains are faster they'll hold
about 380 people that's 25 percent more
passengers than the old ones and are
designed to tilt as they take turns
allowing them to go faster
Amtrak's most lucrative corridor linking
Boston New York and DC will see a cut in
travel time by at least 15 minutes we've
got a position Amtrak to have a modern
product that a millennial wants to get
on
with high-speed Wi-Fi craft beers and
reliable schedules that beat buses cars
and airplanes the new model meets new
stronger crashworthiness standards and
is designed not to jackknife guarding
against the kind of derailment that
killed eight people when Amtrak 188 took
a turn too fast near Philadelphia in
2015 they are the most modern trains in
the world on the inside faster Wi-Fi USB
charging in each seat reading lights and
these winged headrests so no one can
fall asleep on your shoulder anderson
promises unlike the airlines amtrak will
not shrink your seat the space stays the
same i actually would like a little more
space Amtrak is 48 years old the
railroad predicts it's on track to break
even for the first time by 2021 when the
newest sella will start racing along the
Northeast Corridor Stanley Hall plans to
be one of the first passengers it's just
gonna be you know just pry you know
because I know somewhere on that train
there's going to be a plaque that said
that this was manufactured at Nortel New
York